[Music]
so
from our irony files this is like one of
the greatest stories ever so the
university of chicago's institute of
politics and the atlantic magazine just
hosted a conference
no self-awareness whatsoever entitled
disinformation and the erosion of
democracy
so these say they invited all of your
favorite purveyors of disinformation and
exponents of censorship barack obama
jonah goldberg and apple bomb and of
course brian stelcher there was no iq
bar apparently what the speakers didn't
count on the expected hours of just
bloviating is that there are still a
couple of kids at the university of
chicago who are awake enough to say wait
a second what are you talking about
disinformation
here's one exchange
you've all spoken extensively about fox
news being a purveyor of
disinformation
but cnn is right up there with them they
pushed the russian collusion hoax they
pushed the jesse smollett hoax
they smeared justice kavanaugh as a
rapist and they also smeared nick salmon
as a white supremacist and yes they
dismissed the hunter biden laptop affair
as pure russian disinformation all the
mistakes of the mainstream media and cnn
in particular seem to magically all go
in one direction are we expected to
believe that this is all just some sort
of random coincidence or is there
something else behind it i think you're
describing a different channel than the
one that i watch
but i understand that that is a popular
right-wing narrative about cnn
it's a popular right-wing narrative
never trust anyone who uses the term
narrative by the way just for the record
christopher phillips is the man you saw
in that clip he's a freshman at the
university of chicago he joins us
tonight mr phillips thank you for
joining us what possessed you to
confront these purveyors of
disinformation
hi tucker thank you so much for having
me on it's an honor uh you know the the
way i've always been is to uh search for
truth and ask questions to uh you know
sift through the lies and find out
what's really going on so uh myself and
two of my colleagues at the chicago
thinker the university of chicago's
premier publication evita duffy and
daniel schmidt we three went to this
conference and uh you know we see right
when we come in uh a ton of people a ton
of legacy media employees whose entire
careers have been spreading
disinformation those are the people who
are telling us about how to avoid
disinformation so uh you know i hear
brian steltzer and he talks for 30
minutes about how fox news is this huge
purveyor of disinformation they're the
enemy of the people and then i come up
and i say wait a second run that back
because actually cnn uh from my what
i've seen at least is probably 10 times
the purveyor of disinformation that you
claim fox news to be and uh you know he
didn't really have a great answer for it
well i just it you know some of the
examples that you threw at him you know
are subjective i agreed with your with
your take on it but some of them were
just objective like cnn did dismiss
hunter biden's laptop as russian
disinformation that kid's on camera
doing it wouldn't have been better if he
would have said
yeah we got you know i got that wrong
you know i'm sorry about that
wouldn't that have worked
gosh i mean you know i you know to tell
you the truth i didn't exactly expect
him to hand over the keys and say you
know what we're corrupt go ahead chris
and make cnn the truth
um but you know i did uh i did kind of
expect him to say you know we uh
retracted those stories and we apologize
uh right for saying that and we always
uh you know keep it clean we try to keep
a clean record but there was no apology
there was no remorse whatsoever it's
just uh you know i don't know what news
network you're talking about that's not
mine when in reality he said these
things on cnn it's all documented yeah
it's it's hard to have credibility if
you if you want to admit that you make a
mistake ever you know everybody makes
mistakes we certainly have and just
admit it so what was the reaction from
other students at chicago to to your
question
well you know there's a lot of uh social
pressure to uh conform to the leftist
narrative to conform to the radical
agenda at uh college campuses uh so uh
just working for uh the chicago thinker
uh really is um you know kind of
inviting you to be canceled in a sense
but a lot of people i have to say
actually really liked my question they
thought it was fair uh they thought it
was honest and it was pure journalism
and i respect everyone who who told me
that some people were not satisfied with
it but uh regardless you know i think i
think i did a good thing in uh asking
brian you know what gives as to cnn's
bias
yeah and just like i don't just touch
reality once a day you know reassure us
that you're you're not like demented but
he didn't chris phillips from university
of
chicago
a credit to your generation thank you
for coming on
thank you so much tucker and everyone
needs to check out thechicagothinker.com
right now we publish a lot of stuff on
campus craziness uh where no one else is
doing it like we are so hit us on
twitter and instagram as well hit me at
chrispy the truth for more
i looked at it this morning it's good
chris phelps thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight